Nothing happens in a vacuum, this class included.
Now, while many of you may be taking this course because you're interested in
data visualization theory and practice using open source tools like D3,
this class is actually part of the much larger data science track at Udacity.
What I've shown here is a graphic from Ben Fry's PhD thesis,
Computational Information Design.
In it, he describes the larger process surrounding data visualizations,
including acquiring, transforming, and
eventually visualizing data to create engaging and effective graphics.
This whole process maps quite nicely to the data science process as a whole.